what is going on everyone welcome to
part 23 of our matplotlib tutorial
series in this part we're gonna be
talking about is a couple of things one
will continue on what we were talking
about before with the pruning so we're
gonna prune the this X or Y axes this Y
app sees and then we're going to talk
about a new concept which is share
sharing axes so we'll share the y axes
because at the moment first of all you
don't know it yet now you do these these
are not aligned right this is on a
different timeline than this is and this
is so and especially this becomes a true
when we zoom into a specific point on
this axis but the other points aren't
zoomed in so we're gonna handle for that
and then we're also gonna finish up
pruning here so let's do the pruning
first so this is where we were pruning
the y axes on ax 1 let's copy that and
we're gonna come down to ax 2 here paste
and for this one we could have more than
5 so let's do like I don't know 7 it's a
bigger chart and then we'll prune the
upper from ax 2 and then we'll copy this
copy come down to ax 3 stuff will come
right here paste ax 3 number of Bin's
5 and we definitely want to prune the
upper on this one so let's run that real
quick and see how clean this looks it's
looking good at the point at the moment
pretty good we might want to change the
bins though like maybe on the the top
and the bottom one instead of five let's
do four four let's save and run that one
yeah okay that looks a little better so
we'll go ahead and stand stick with that
for now so now we want to talk about
sharing x axes so the way that we share
an x axis is actually pretty simple all
we have to do is we come up to where
we're defining our plots and it really
doesn't matter which one we share the
axes with but it just kind of makes
sense that since we're defining them in
one two three order we have a X to share
the x axis with a x one and we have a x3
share the x-axes with again ax1 so the
way that we share x-axis is just with
this share X and then share X will equal
the axes that you want to share so this
would be a x1 and then we do the exact
same thing copy that paste to a x3 so
now everyone's sharing the X axes
together and we can really get a feel
for this by it now let's save and run
and we can see what is different now so
loading this up now they're together and
the first thing that you should notice
is that the moving average starts over
here rather than all the way over to the
left and that's because of that start
point stuff so now though if we zoom
into a specific spot like here
everything zooms in together right so no
longer are we only zooming into one
graph at a time we zoom into all graphs
at a time when we zoom in and now the
dates are all aligned as we really need
them to be okay so the thing that I
would change at this point especially if
say for example let's close these
instead of one year let's say we were
doing a time frame of maybe six months
this should be even more pronounced same
to run that and yeah it looks a little
more pronounced where you know the
moving average is just starting way
later than everything else so what if we
wanted to trim everything else well you
can and you should do that I'm going to
change this back to one year just cuz I
like the more data but the way that we
can hand over that is now that we have
we have the start point right that's
defined up here okay so we apply that
minus start : basically to everyone okay
so that was a x3 gets it but we can
apply that start point really to
everyone so x1 where we're plotting date
and high minus low - start : - start :
then when we go do the candlestick we're
plotting on a x2 the open high low close
of - start : and then getting to a x3
we've already done it so now let's go
ahead and save and run that and now
everything's lined up right we don't
have this issue anymore
of you know charts starting at different
points basically because that was kind
of silly now I think that's all I want
to do in this one sharing the x-axis is
a pretty common common question so I
kind of wanted to have that be mainly
what this tutorial was about but with
that you can share the x-axis also
that's not a you know that's not a
function that's only applicable to the
subplot two grid so if you're following
along with the other add subplot kind of
syntax this should work just fine for
you as well I'm trying to get tore
defining yeah right here there we go so
if you're falling if you're following
along doing the add subplot stuff this
should the share X should still work no
problem now as we move on what we're
going to talk about next is we still
have one data set that is not covered
yet yet is also on like a lot of stock
plots and that's volume and with volume
what I'm going to show you guys is how
we can have multiple y axes so we've
shown you guys how to have multiple
subplots how to share an x-axis but what
about how do you almost sort of share
the same figure with another graph only
have like double y axes so it's a way to
plot two different series that are on
totally different scales right so stock
price is in you know 50s but stock
volume might be in the millions or the
hundreds of thousands a day so that's
what we're gonna talk about in the next
tutorial is how we can have a double y
axes share the x axis which is date but
plot another bit of data on this same
chart so that's all we're gonna talk
about in the next tutorial if you have
questions comments concerns whatever up
to this point please do feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support in the subscriptions and until
the next video